hi I'm Jen and I'm Nikki today we're
discussing the untold stories of queer
people throughout history because they
definitely exist jen has a pipe and we
have a gavel huh so what could possibly
go wrong today we are talking about the
American treasure Eleanor Roosevelt who
is rumored to have had relationships
with both men and women lots of rumors
lots of stories we're gonna get into it
today what do you know about her I know
this huge married to see the adore
Roosevelt who she's married to
Eleanor Roosevelt was born October 11th
1884 to a wealthy family in New York
City unfortunately by age 10 everyone
was dead so like she like went to live
with other relatives I'm like the
brother who lived in 1903
Eleanor got engaged to Franklin
Roosevelt her fifth cousin once-removed
you think they kiss with tongue
background absolutely after they married
Franklin's political career really
started ramping up so this is where
things get a little bit scandalous okay
so Franklin ended up cheating on Eleanor
with Eleanor's secretary which is pretty
shitty because Eleanor's secretary is
probably like somebody was pretty close
to her knew what her schedule was knew
where she was at all the time and then
was just like all right cool she's busy
let me go [ __ ] her husband real quick
also he wasn't hot just like you're
really gonna risk your career for
someone it's like I hope they're hot and
like not racist he didn't check either
one of those boxes so Eleanor first find
out about this she was like [ __ ] this
let's get divorced because she was not
down for it but as you know divorce when
you're in the political limelight like
that's bad at connecting to your career
you that press people think differently
of you so Franklin was like look I
promised him the affair if you stay with
me and she was like fine but pretty much
after that their marriage was never the
same
when Franklin took office in 1933 as the
president Eleanor kept on doing her own
damn thing his First Lady of the United
States
she was very politically active and she
started a weekly press conference for
just female journalists who are
typically not allowed in other press
conferences again just surrounding
herself with ladies
okay now's where we get to the gate it
is both juicy and steamy Elinor's
biographer and many others believe the
first lady was in a relationship with
one Lorena Hickok Lorena Hickok is a
reporter named hick was said to have
each drank smoked gambled and swore like
a classic butch lesbian to me yeah she
sounds fun
so although hick and Elinor knew each
other for a few years it wasn't until
hick was assigned to cover Elinor during
Franklin's presidential campaign in 1932
that they really got to know each other
when hip wasn't on the road for her job
she actually lived out of the White
House and she gave Elinor a ring that
Eleanor would wear publicly that sounds
gay the fact that Hickling lived in the
White House and gave her a ring and like
no one thought anything of it like no
one was ever like oh I wonder if those
two are just like [ __ ] each other I
think that speaks to heterosexism
because they were like it's unfathomable
the two women could find a relationship
and have pleasure from it anyways okay
so when hick and Eleanor weren't
together they were writing each other
letters and that's where we have proof
the two of them exchanged more than 3300
letters between 1932 and shortly before
Eleanor died like why would you do that
you weren't like kind of obsessed with
somebody I don't know what did you ask
me
so these letters they were exchanging
are they romantic in nature aren't they
oh okay do you like to read some okay
we're gonna read some so picture this
Eleanor in her nightie pondering to the
moon her snoring president of a husband
she doesn't sleep with anymore snoring
in the next room she saunters to her
desk and pulls out a quill were they I
don't think they were using quills back
then hey I had probably using pens okay
this is what she says hick my dearest I
cannot go to bed tonight without a word
to you you have grown so much to be a
part of my life that it is empty without
you even though I am busy every minute
Oh goddamn that's saucy wouldn't you say
that to somebody you weren't like
hmm you know no you wouldn't that's not
something you said into a friend a
little uncomfortable here you read that
it's how into minute is now we kept a
hick out on the lonely road as a
reporter nothing to keep her company and
night but our cigarettes in the distant
memory of Eleanor's lips here you read
this fight most clearly voice most
clearly I remember your eyes with a kind
of reassuring smile in them and the
feeling of the soft spot just northeast
of the corner of your mouth against my
lips I wonder what we'll do when we meet
what we'll say what is northeast corner
what if this is just a nick revealing
she is the worst kisser in the world
just kisses right here every time I only
like this part it gets better it gets
better in there's more oh how I wanted
to put my arms around you in reality
instead of spirit I went and kissed your
photograph instead and tears were in my
eyes these are like I'm in love with you
yeah and they didn't just write letters
to each other they also spent hours on
the phone and allegedly ended every call
with you Tim Asia tada which means get
the door [ __ ] No that means I love you
and I adore you oh it's very sweet he's
really sweet very sweet feelings towards
each other so it's pretty clear L&R was
into women at least this woman can
confirm as for Franklin he died in 1945
and sadly Eleanor and hixx relationship
also ended we're not sure by how or why
it's not out of the realm of possibility
to that they just like drifted apart
couldn't spend time together
to other lovers after Franklin died she
joined the United Nations General
Assembly after an appointment from
President Truman and several times
during her life she was voted world's
most admired woman so she lives an
honored and admired lady so again
probably why she couldn't be like I like
boys and girls
so we learned something new today that
they don't teach you the history books I
mean that's pretty cool there was like a
powerful queer woman run and [ __ ] and
falling in love in the White House yes
years and years ladies have had sex with
each other in the White House that's my
favorite fact about the way
[Music]